Davis had a deep post up they couldn't
get it to him they turned it over pumpin
Gentry was weary of his team being able
to play at a fast pace and yet not turn
the ball over that's not a turnover
that's Davis on the slam inside Davis
working against Campello Anthony Davis
gets the layup
he's got six but like that's big-time
warts and stuff Anthony Davis nothing
ill-fitting about that jet run the
Rookie of the Year missing and back
comes Randall and Anthony Davis or he
was wide open for a long time finally
delivered on Beach State makes for the
seven-point game Davis fouled and
they're going to count it like that's
not like some surprise
Matheny Davis was working out this
summer finishes the alley-oop big
defender that like most guys who
struggled with their range shooting what
a pass oh Anthony Davis with the time to
holiday in New Orleans a game that I was
able to call the game in which Cousins
Torres Achilles tendon with two seconds
to go in the game Davis inside continues
to dominate and Payton with the book
Dayton with the LOB in a classy finish
by Anthony Davis timeout magton Tony
especially with all these charter
flights that's the big deal travel
implications used to be one of the
impacts or potential impacts job not
fouling James Harden's pulling their
hands back an another alley-oop slam
and James Harden injured at the other
end